[Music]
people say that like oh like we're doing
this because let go can be ballet so
this is an alternative it has nothing to
do with that I will tell you every girl
in this studio is classically trained
everyone does ballet and everything else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is the poor Wilson and I'm a hit
lady dancer Hitler is a mixture of
hip-hop and ballet but really anything
that we can try to put on point that
have like a groovy feel into it
my name is Homer Hansbrough and I'm the
founder of hip leg and the founder and
director of the Chicago multicultural
Dance Center
I think some people get mad where we
stay see us during a play it's not
traditional classical ballet we're
ruining ballet well no it's not ballet
is hit play is how we empower our kids
is how we empower the world hip leg is
so freeing and so open there's a
different culture here the hit land
movements are the hip lifts truck that
twist in and out the moonwalk the Vivian
and the Ricky you have to have a certain
posture when you're doing ballet
usually here at all like straight figure
posture everything pointe shoes were
designed for ballet hit play is
different and hip late you can break
that you can just really move your torso
more you can bounce with it you know you
can have fun with it I grew up thinking
that I couldn't do ballet because of the
color of my skin at my old studio
because I was african-american I was
often overlooked until I came to seeing
disease when I really learned that there
was something off I'm grateful to
mission a homer because he showed me
that I can do anything I love dancing
and hip lit it just gives you a sort of
a confidence and just a free don't like
just to be yourself this is the dance
genre that does not discriminate
we have rhythm and you can do at one
point you got it